اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من غلاف غزه اهلا
بكم معارك ضاريه في مناطق عده بقطاع غزه
وكتائب القسام تعلن التصدي لمحاولات
اسرائيليه للتقدم في جباليا وتبث صورا
لاستهداف اليات بمعسكر الجعبري وتقول انها
تشتبك مع قوات الاحتلال في خان يونس
والاذاعه الاسرائيليه تؤكد ان قاده كبارا
يجمعون على ان غياب رؤيه سياسيه لما بعد
الحرب سيحول دون تحقيق نصر على حماس قوات
الاحتلال تقصف احياء سكنيه من جباليا
شمالا الى خانيونس جنوبا والصحه
الفلسطينيه تقول ان القصف اوقع
165 شهيدا خلال الساعات ال4 الماضيه في
حين يواجه النازحون في قطاع غزه اوضاعا
معيشيه صعبه بعد ان اجبرتهم قوات الاحتلال
على مغادره مدارس
الاونروا تزامنا مع خلافات داخل اروقه صنع
القرار في اسرائيل بسبب الحرب على غزه
مئات الاسرائيليين يعتصمون بمحيط منزل
نتنياهو في قيساريا للمطالبه بابرام صفقه
فوريه للافراج عن الاسرى الاسرائيليين في
غزه وبايدن يبحث مع نتنياهو حل الدولتين
ويقول ان اقامه دوله فلسطينيه ليست
مستحيله بوجودنا نتنياهو الذي لا يعارض
المساله غدات استشهاد فلسطيني برصاص
الاحتلال شرقي مدينه رام الله مستوطنون
يهاجمون مزارعين فلسطينيين في قريه رمون
ويصيبون احدهم بالراس وقوات الاحتلال
تقتحم مدينه بيت لحم وبلده بني نعيم شرقي
الخليل الى
اللقاء